Nhi là man xà về người đen ông hãng hử khi mất luôn cả nhà, đất.
Theo ông chờn bà định, năm 2018, chú tại xà ăn hoa, quyền lưu, viên chào mẹ không định được với nhau,
nên ông được mẹ sao cho ông bà hoại nguyên tử lúc mới chào đời.
Năm một gình chính trăm chính mấy sấu sau khi sất mũ, ông định chờ với quay,
mùa hồn mạnh đất mạng tỉnh lộ, mấy xà 2 chụ đồng, này chung thậm xả để dựng nhá,
vừa sĩnh thống vừa là người thất hoặc.
Mạnh đất này có sẽ đic bột chăm mất vùng, đip xác với chương vọng đơn xả ăn hoa.
Một thời gian sau công việc là man không thật lựng,
nên ông định giữ người em họ là ông bóng hòc hông sau mấy hai tuổi, chú tại xà ăn hoa,
trong con nhà có mình đi vào viên năm mùa xin.
Vì bận việc ở quay cũng không còn bánh người tân lưỡa, nên tôi sẽ tích khi về thăm nhà.
Ông định nói, nơi ngàn không cho ông về chiến, ông định về quay thì ngã người khi thấy nhà,
đất của mình đã chở thành quân viên của chương vực nôn.
Thì đến họ về em họ, ông định mới hai biết,
mạnh đất của ông đã bị chính quay xà ăn hoa tuổi để mự sọng khuôn kên trường mặc nôn từ năm 2018.
Đúc đó, giá bảo sẽ lối cho một khá đất khác, tôi không nghĩ đơn giản đây là việc tốt,
làm đẹp cho con viên bột chương học, đi đầu vi bản ra đất cho xà,
nhưng chở máy họ có đông thực hiện lời gửa của mình.
Ông hùng nói, việc tù hồi đất chỉ thống qua người em họ có ông định.
Người đe nông này sau đối đến lập việc với người bản nhân dân xà,
và chấp nhận với lời vụ của xà là sẽ đổi cho ông một thử đất khác.
Thuy nhiên, đánh nhiều năm cho qua,
lời hồi đỏ với chờ được thực hiện,
hệ ông định vẫn đang mới đi tuy nhà cho để ương.
Được xà, tôi hồi đất của tôi để mở giống chương mắm nó là việc tốt,
tôi cũng đồng ý với việc này.
Sự việc bây giờ đã lửa rồi,
nhà đã phá tôi cũng không yêu cầu bôi thường.
Mà hiện tạc có nhiều một phật trong các cho quay hương.
Tôi chỉ yêu cầu, cấp một mạnh đất khác,
hợp bôi thương mạnh tiền để mua bột mạnh đất khác là nhà,
để cuộc sống mặt tôi, ông định nói.